hey guys Pete peppers here and we got a
sneak preview of the new addition and
the candy crush saga series candy crush
jelly saga and this is a quick you know
playthrough show you what the gameplay
looks like some of the new features
wasn't sure when I first heard about
this why they would make a brand new one
while soda is still so popular but I
think this this mode here the spread
more jam than the Queen or just played
the Queen in general is a pretty good
idea of why this is something that they
don't have an A in the other games and I
can't think of any game that actually
has the has this kind of gameplay so the
basic idea is is that you know there's a
queen who also takes turns with you so
you have the eye of the purple jam or
jelly and she has the green jelly so the
goal is to spread it out and have more
than her when it's done right so another
thing I can do is I can make specials
and whenever I do that I will get an
extra move however I don't want to
really make them on hers because it'll
spread hers anyway so I'm just gonna go
ahead and take a safe move on the first
one you can see she made a special so
she gets two now it's my turn again and
it's pretty cool you know you actually
you're actually playing against the
machine now she's not perfect obviously
she makes some pretty clear mistakes but
hey that's alright
it's still pretty pretty interesting and
it's definitely not you know she's not a
pushover so you can see there I added a
couple extra moves I'm gonna set up this
hopefully she won't mess it up I had an
extra move couple extra moves there for
making specials and you could see that
every round it takes a turn off of here
I don't have to take all of her color
out
I just have to have more left at the end
but I can take hers out and then attends
it sooner as well so that's always fun
you get a couple extra points for that
and I was hoping I would get it here and
I did so that's how the dam1 works you
just take turns trying to cover hers up
I'll show you one more game mode real
quick
so let's alright so the other new thing
that's in the game so far is the the
critters and this is a critters level
that is up against the Queen as well so
it's telling me that if I make a special
I get an extra turn and it's telling me
that the Queen will add frosting so I'm
trying to remove the frosting just like
the Bears levels and soda except for
these ones have critters and she's going
to put it back on so same rules apply if
I make specials I get an extra move and
you can see where the critters start out
they're here and here and they can
actually move around which is kind of
kind of interesting but um she's not
getting a term because I keep making
specials and that's all right by me and
I'm gonna go ahead and shoot this off
and you know the fish can go anywhere so
she takes her turn and now you see that
they moved around a little bit
and these are not these are not the most
difficult levels I don't want you to
think it's super simple but it is
actually a little a little easy right
now I'm sure they'll make it a little
bit tougher it's really early in the
development and you know it's it's got a
lot of work to go still so I think it
has a lot of promise I'm pretty excited
about it you know it could be months
until we see the full version but I
wanted to go ahead and you know give you
an idea what it looks like what we have
in store down the road hope you'll enjoy
it please like the video if you found it
interesting tell your friends if they
play candy crush the you know watch it
and see what's going on please subscribe
to my channel and we'll definitely I
have all 40 levels that are out now up
and I'll keep keep them up to date just
like I do with my other games and try to
have a playlist that has the most recent
version that shows off all the changes
and everything and now you know we got a
we just started our Facebook group so
make sure you join us and you can find
that in the comment talk to you soon